so I'm also really excited as well now
so basically so basically so and this
happens to do people all the time
[Music]
twenty-seven visual sex shop
well yeah done by seven so no like this
is not it's not gonna be done by Friday
I'm in New York City today because I'm
shooting a promotional video with Dwayne
the rock Johnson this is a really
intense experience for myself he's like
literally the biggest celebrity right
now and I have to admit I'm usually not
starstruck but I I'm pretty nervous
about meeting him because he's such an
intense guy I have been selected to go
into our promotional video for lifeline
with him we only have 20 minutes with
him we have all night to prepare and set
up our set for the shoot
on the rock we're gonna seal this goat
with any luck about 2:00 in the morning
now we have taken our large hotel suite
here and we've converted it into a small
set complete with lights and a white
backdrop because tomorrow morning we
have 20 minutes of shooting we have to
be 100% ready so we just spent all night
free lighting everything hotel rooms so
fancy is crazy
there's even like a secret door here
that opens up to a whole nother room
[Music]
these new most expensive looking room
I've ever stayed in in my entire life
that means that's average nine shots per
day excluding whatever shots I'm able to
get done today most of the effects are
compositing in a green-screen element
onto a wall and that's actually pretty
simple because it's a shadow you're just
going to turn that plate into black and
white
[Music]
Nicholas I'm able to keep dreaming
shadows pretty quickly we have to have
all the effects done by tomorrow and
there's still a lot of those effects
left to do
so Gabe I am I am recruiting you to do
some very tedious stuff that takes a lot
of time because if you can take that off
my plate I think I might be able to
finish all the rest of it better on
screen capturing your screen capturing
this shot this was longer yeah but
you're describing things they're
happening in this Mulder look so breath
getting dragged across the floor and we
have to basically paint out all of Jake
but not paint out the back so we got the
footage here I turn it off we have an
exact replica of the background do a
past where you literally just the mask
straight up through and over set that
just subtract now that we basically cut
out Jake for the entirety of the shot
you need to add back in bread so that's
how this is a two-stage process here
exactly we are out of water full 47 and
we are minutes away from actually
shooting this thing and I'm a here
Corinne works people were with Dennis
our DP were with Scott from seven bucks
we're with Kurt who's generally cool guy
who's helped us figure let it set up
Frankie right now everyone's finally
starting to arrive meaning it's about to
get very very real Hey this smell what
The Rock is talking
[Music]
really if I mean look at our state
attention here I see ok so I see so sing
copy all the way through two times just
different totally what we're going to do
any data Scott yeah and so what it
really just happens to be in that space
yeah in terms of the motion reality
everyone to blatantly and also you don't
know clients don't know how this works
they don't know that contract was
involved it'll write those down it's
just in here am i right
okay great other stuff is actually
pretty good at After Effects so I'm like
got i've got no worries
should I be worried this video has 29
visual effects shots the vast majority
of them aren't too complicated and I can
go through fairly quickly I've already
kicked out I think six shots today but
rotoscoping is one of those things that
just kind of takes a lot of time but in
the time it would take me to do the
backpack shot just wrote oh hang out the
backpack and getting that shot done I
could have probably done two or three
shadow shots so just like logistically
speaking with our schedule it makes more
sense to pass that off to someone else
Retin red makes it look so easy
he's really good at like animation and
whatnot in After Effects considering
this is the first time he's ever using
the rotor brush it's hard for me to say
how long it'll take me to do I would
probably take me I'm not even like
remotely worried that Gabe's not going
to get this done for right sometime here
I could be I could be doing some green
screening that's not my side left
anyways this
my sign that's my point yeah who's
responsible for that that but you
brought me in here
today's finished those two shots that
are excellent good job did you tender
more now if he hit those so quickly like
in World War II and just yet got another
couple hours I have since we last saw
finishing of this one right now so
that's three more I'm almost done with
this shot so I actually think I might be
able to get all these done by tomorrow
wait so this is Thursday evening right
now and this is going up in tomorrow's
blog okay let's get you guys still shots
we got a film and there's still a drone
shot I gotta get
you're going to all that car yeah and
there's like a whole bunch of work here
actually Gabe can help me with that
stuff I'll tell you tomorrow
oh there will this master Jonathan babe
on here so I know it is a community go
it's go watch that video Johnny Boz is
great I pretty much stuck with it ever
since
you know works not consistently the only
downside is that I can't wear shirts
with sleeves anymore you don't like
muscles are too big